let me pose a question to you ladies
let's say you don't get married let's
just say
and you're 40 years old and you've got
an amazing career
amazing career but you never got married
would that be disappointing to you
i would be disappointed for me marriage
is not
that important anymore i want to have a
partner and i want to be with somebody i
i would like to get married and get
engaged and you know build this
life with someone okay but that's not
something that
that's my like sole purpose in life so
if you were 40 yeah they never got
married
no kids i'm just hypothetical no kids
but you had a good career i would like
would that be enough to satisfy you i
would i always wanted to be a mother so
i i want to be a mom and before i'm 40
yeah because of like all the of course
no that's why i put it that way so i
would definitely want to be a mother and
i would be disappointed if i'm not a
mother okay how about you ally if you
never got married and you're still work
on your career let's say you're an
influencer but you're still single would
that be a disappointment there would
absolutely be a disappointment that's
not how i want my life going down at all
and you know there's something to be
said about if you don't have babies your
dna doesn't go on and you're really just
kind of like well you know life is
pointless i think kids give women
purpose and i think that we lie to women
when we tell them that that's not true
that your job is going to fulfill you
it's not the same thing as watching a
tiny human grow look and look up at you
and learn but you know i've noticed
sometimes that women will say that they
want kids but they won't say that they
want a specific man's kiss and i think
that's an important distinction
how do you mean what's the distinction
there so okay um for people that follow
my content they're pretty familiar that
i had a miscarriage earlier this year i
ended up going to facebook support
groups because i don't know who else to
talk to about that stuff i ended up
going there and i found two very
different schools of thought there are
women that were married and in
relationships where they wanted to have
children but it didn't work out but then
there were other women that were
grieving but they're just looking for a
guy to get the job done like they're
literally hunting for men to impregnate
them they haven't given a thought well i
mean what's the cost going to be to the
child so i think like if we're going to
talk about women wanting to have
children and that's like in the plans
then like you know uh i know sperm is
cheap but we still need it we still need
it so you know what what's up with the
guy where he's where's he at how are we
gonna get him okay and then pearl if
you're 40
youtube blown up million subscribers you
killed it but no husband no kids would
that be satisfying none of it would
matter like like to me if you have
nothing to pass on and like you
who cares if you're rich if you're alone
you can have all the money in the world
but if you don't have like a family to
go home to that's sad i
i um i did this thing where i
interviewed um executives like top
executives in milwaukee and
there was a couple that i interviewed
that like had no family no kids and you
could just see how sad they were
and i like who cares if you have all the
success if you have no one to share it
with yeah that makes me think i have a
couple of friends down here in south
florida they're both
i would say very successful estate
planners right so high profile lawyers
estate
planners and they were both you're
familiar with the concept of dinks
dual income no kids oh yes stinks
and they're both you know crushing six
figures easily
um and they were not gonna have kids
and then
lo and behold i think after like 10
years of marriage
they decided to have kids now they're on
their second kid because they realized
holy [ __ ] i don't know what i was
thinking here okay by the way is this
something this discussion that we're
having right now is this something that
women sit around and discuss no this is
not
just just uh okay why is this not uh
like guys we will should you know what
up bros you know girl yeah here's what
i'm thinking yeah like why don't women
have these types of discussion why does
it take saucecast on valuetainment
subscribe right now to bring this type
of conversation to the forefront why
don't ladies have this discussion do you
want to weigh in ladies don't have
watercolors this discussion right here
they both nodded their head and said no
they don't talk about this do you talk
about this kind of stuff with your
friends stuff like wanting to career
women getting married
of course being a housewife rather than
an independent woman so you're saying
you do have these conversations we don't
really talk about all of them i try to
surround myself with people who are very
ambitious and career driven so i can
learn from them and like we can all
build each other up
so but we never talk about like oh if i
don't get married if i don't do this
like we're all talking about just like
so building a career one of the are you
ready to take some calls in a second to
tell you um one sec but one of the terms
that i constantly hear because i'm
asking
all sorts of people um
what specifically women
on
traits or qualities they find attractive
in a man
and
a term that constantly gets put out
there is ambition
he's ambitious oh my god he hasn't made
it yet but he's ambitious he's got some
drive he's got ambition that's
attractive it's attractive quality
i don't know if men are like oh that
girl right there she's ambitious i love
how ambitious she is they're not okay so
guys i don't care about that your
boyfriend he loves the fact that you're
ambitious yeah but you said boyfriend is
it oh meaning that's not her husband how
do you mean i would be curious right so
if coco and this guy right they end up
working on the long term if he's a
masculine man i'd be i would wonder if
you'd be in the kitchen making some
breakfast we both make breakfast i made
it today he made it yesterday okay i
mean i think it works for you guys no i
don't i don't need photo proof i'm just
saying i would be curious to see if that
femininity switch would flip for you
so is there a switch that women have to
basically tap into is that what you're
saying well i think women should
consider femininity from the beginning
but the west is just really awful at it
i think eastern culture has femininity
figured out way more but i think some
women they're ambitious boss babe that's
all i care about but then they meet a
strong masculine man they're like okay
you know what like maybe i'll work
part-time you know how okay how do you
want your steak medium rare what kind of
side do you want i've seen it happen in
real time women are like i would never
serve a man and then they have the hot
plate in their hands i cook for my man
yeah i have no shame in admitting that i
mean in europe we learn how to cook like
every woman pretty much knows how to
cook but that's not something that
like i'm not gonna not work because like
i need to make a meal like making a meal
is
something very normal in my life yeah
there's a difference between making a
meal and making a home
yeah well i mean there's
a maid can like clean for you a cook can
cook for you but only a wife can make a
home
so that's like family traditions culture
and like what are you passing on to your
children
gotcha so that's again your dream life
is to be
you know happy wife happy life but your
dream like forget about a million
subscribers you want to make a house a
home
yeah i just want a lot of kids like i
think i'm pretty cool so i feel like if
there's like five of me running around
that'd be like
it'd be even cooler you're ready for
what kind of stupid by the way guys in
the super chat we're going to be
answering your questions today uh we're
we're these women as as
i just want to thank you guys for being
here and everyone has a different uh
opinion respect everyone's getting along
great but i do want to answer some of
the questions from
um valuetainers out there in the
audience and tell you got something that
you want to ask um so there's one
question from nate
throughman he said why would a man that
values marriage want to marry you that's
a question who me just in general oh why
okay
so i'm like yeah so why would a man who
values marriage want to marry you okay
go down the line here coco you go first
why would a man who values marriage
would want to marry me yes
i'm not really sure if i understand that
question
so a guy who wants to get married yeah
why would he want to marry you oh so
basically you're asking me what it
brings to the table or what is that yeah
is that what it is sure and we'll go
down the line this you're not being
singled out okay no no i know
um
well
it's a very strange question honestly
for me but i would want to marry
somebody that i see building i if i'm
with my boyfriend now and i see
marrying him one day if we get to that
point because he is a good partner he
helps me do certain things and i help
him
and i
i would it's easier to live life with
somebody
but that's not like my end goal like i'm
not going to put everything on the side
so i can like live life with someone but
you know when you're grocery shopping
it's nice to do it with someone i don't
have that answer so your answer is like
look i'm going to be a good partner i'm
going to bring mine i like i like i'm
going to bring something to the table
but you're going to bring something to
the table but we're going to do this
together yeah and also like i always
like him and i currently like we
things that he's good at
i'm not and vice versa and also like i
totally agree a woman should be able to
make a home because guys don't really
know how to make a home yeah they don't
know how to how to decorate the
apartment they don't know the flowers
are nice in the apartment they don't
know that like your utensils should
match and [ __ ] so like
you know i'm guilty of all that by the
way
um ally why would a man or why did your
husband want to marry you
why wouldn't he marry me no i'm kidding
so it's basically
my perspective on marriage is a little
bit interesting
being in that feminine role where i
fully depend on my husband i believe
that gives him purpose so i think that
he's had a greater sense of appreciation
for the work that he does so it's more
fulfilling and he can cope with the
stress more because well you know he's
doing it for me and he's coming home to
me also i make sure that he's rewarded
for his hard work and his efforts he
pretty much can lean on me in times of
trouble but also we can also enjoy each
other in times of great joy and that's
that's a really fun thing a lot of
people don't know this my husband was a
50 year old bachelor mm-hmm about 48
year old bachelor when i met him so he
he tells me even now that i add value to
his life and when i think about marriage
as a business it's like
drum it incorporated how can i make our
our brand our family our business how
can i make it so that we can thrive how
much bigger can we make this drum and
household name and that's my approach to
marriage so i if if you want a really
good hard worker as your wife like
that's what i think i bring together got
it um one follow-up question before we
get to pearl
you said your husband when you met him
he was 48 yes and now he's 50. she's
been married give or take two years
together two years was he successful
before he met you
oh i think he was very successful oh yes
yes i hung out at the finish line and i
got a winner
but that's a thing
i do think it's a thing and so eric can
you turn me up a little bit i'm down a
little bit
so when i met him he was very
accomplished in the military that's the
thing is a lot of women wouldn't think
that my husband makes enough money but
i'm a badge bunny i'm like a masculinity
honey that's what i'm looking for what
is a badge bunny a badge money is a
woman who likes cops firefighters
service members so a man in uniform yes
yes a man in uniform so he's a a major
and he's got all these shiny medals and
i'm like sir
sir pick me marry me choose me and yeah
so i know that a lot of women wouldn't
think that he makes enough but we live
in the midwest so it's like more than
enough money to go around and then you
know i've got the muscles to make up for
it so there you go um all right pearl
why would a man want to marry you
um i i do my best to be an asset in a
guy's life in whatever way that i can so
with my last boyfriend i was always like
cooking and cleaning um and i'd like
manage some of his business stuff
so when i when i'm like going into a
relationship i just want to i always
think about like what can i do to help
this guy like
his life be easier day to day i think